[Música]
a
el estado de nueva york que en un
principio fue el epicentro de esta
pandemia recoge en estos momentos unas
de las mejores cifras que se pueden ver
en este país desde hace 30 días el nivel
de contagio se encuentra por debajo del
1%
además las hospitalizaciones han bajado
a niveles que no se veían desde el
pasado 16 de marzo y la media de
fallecidos por kobe 19 oscila entre los
3 y los 7 muertos diarios
nueva yor avanza lentamente en esa
reapertura de momento los museos
gimnasios centros comerciales y casinos
ya han abierto sus puertas pero con una
capacidad reducida broadway además ha
anunciado que no levantará el telón
hasta el 2021 y los restaurantes todavía
no pueden servir comida en su interior
solo en las terrazas todo ello hace
pensar y hace dudar cuáles serán las
cifras y seguirán siendo igual de buenas
una vez el estado vuelva realmente y
completamente a la normalidad
[Música]
seis meses de pandemia brasil sigue
siendo el país más afectado de américa
latina con más de 4 millones de
contagiados y casi 130 mil muertos los
datos muestran desde hace un mes una
bajada constante de los casos sin
embargo los expertos advierten que hay
que mantener la cautela porque puede
llegar una segunda ola y la tónica en
este primer semestre han sido las
polémicas el presidente de brasil y jair
bolsonaro siempre minimizó el virus
incluso lo llegó a llamar una pequeña
gripe abogó por mantener activa la
economía y llegó a pelearse con los
principales gobernadores del país que
instauraron fuertes medidas de
cuarentena también bolsonaro ha sido un
gran defensor de la cloroquina un
polémico medicamento experimental que
todavía suscita suspicacias en el mundo
científicos de hecho precisamente por
esa razón cayeron dos ministros de
sanidad y el actual para suelo es
interino desde el mes de mayo y es el
que ha implantado el protocolo de la
cloroquina eso sí la popularidad de
bolsonaro sigue subiendo
es la más alta desde el inicio de la
pandemia el 37% de los encuestados están
a favor de su gestión
[Música]
hace semanas que se habla ya de la
segunda ola de la pandemia en españa
pero las autoridades sanitarias
advierten de que a pesar que las cifras
de contagios sean altas la situación es
mucho más calmada que la que teníamos al
inicio de la pandemia y es que los
números de contagios de positivos son
altos pero los de fallecimientos se
mantienen relativamente muy bajos en la
última semana no hemos superado los 50
fallecimientos por día siendo en algunos
días estando esta cifra todavía por
debajo de los 20 además se están
haciendo muchísimos más tests pcr de los
que se hacían durante la primavera pero
por otro lado lo que parece fallar en
españa está en la detección de los casos
asintomáticos y ahora con el inicio de
las clases preocupa que los centros
educativos puedan ser un centro de
transmisión sin embargo en estos días
que llevamos ya de cursos el número de
aulas que se han debido cerrar son muy
pocas y sólo se aíslan a los compañeros
de la persona que ha dado positivo sin
embargo eso sí por parte de los
sanitarios se quejan de que no están
preparados a nivel material ni de
recursos humanos para afrontar una
situación como la que se dio durante la
primavera
[Música]